in the tiny pacific paradise of guam
operation iron island is underway
as china ramps up its military
capabilities in the region u.s forces
are testing the iron dome a defense
system capable of firing missiles that
intercept short-range threats like
rockets mortars drones and cruise
missiles
it's not that big no it's not and then
you can tell how big the interceptors
would be right right little pods right
chief warrant officer caroline suprenant
specializes in the army's missile
defense systems she says the iron dome
could provide a new layer of defense as
threats in the region grow
what are these interceptors capable of
doing while the platform is fixed for
the missile firing unit you'll see that
the interceptors are able to maneuver
towards the threat
it's the same system israel uses to
shoot down rockets from gaza and it has
been 90 percent effective testing of the
iron dome here comes just months after a
top military leader warned that guam's
defenses are inadequate against threats
from china guam is a target today
it needs to be defended and it needs to
be prepared for the threats that will
come in the future so what exactly is
the army testing and would the iron dome
be enough to protect this u.s territory
which is playing an increasingly
important role in america's strategy to
counter china
it's often said that america's day
begins in guam a volcanic island just 36
miles long and blessed with lush
mountains beautiful beaches and stunning
sunsets
west of the international date line guam
is roughly one-third the distance to
china and north korea as it is to the
mainland united states and the military
bases on guam are the closest on
american soil to the places where china
has been exerting military influence in
taiwan and the south china sea
she was here
two commanders as a result military
officials say guam's strategic
importance is growing what role would
guam play in the event of a conflict in
the event of any military
operations for the united states in the
pacific region
guam plays a role rear admiral benjamin
nicholson oversees all u.s forces in
guam and joint region marianas part of
what the pentagon says is america's
priority theater and a region in which
the military says china is a top concern
what does it mean when you hear the
secretary of defense say china is the
number one pacing threat you always want
to pace against whoever's the fastest
runner whoever can go the longest the
farthest that's where you set your pace
and in today's environment that really
becomes china they're doing the most
build up they're doing it the quickest
with the most advanced weapons
admiral nicholson and other officials we
spoke to said that the iron domes
deployment is fulfilling a congressional
requirement and is not a direct response
to china but it comes as the defense
department released new details about
china's growing nuclear capabilities
china has been expanding its nuclear
arsenal much faster than previously
thought according to a recent pentagon
report beijing could have about 700
nuclear warheads in the next six years
and defense experts say some of the
weapons it's been testing could
potentially complicate u.s defenses
according to the report released in
early november china may have already
established a nuclear triad the ability
to launch nukes from the air land and
sea beijing is also developing new mervs
intercontinental ballistic missiles
capable of delivering multiple warheads
to multiple targets the term mirv is an
acronym for multiple independently
targetable re-entry vehicles and over
the summer china surprised u.s officials
when it tested a hypersonic missile that
orbited the earth before maneuvering
toward its target
while the u.s still has roughly 11 times
more missiles than china according to
the federation of american scientists
the build-up has alarmed some military
leaders
and while the iron dome wouldn't be
capable of defending against some of
china's more sophisticated missiles it
could be used to counter the country's
growing fleet of bombers that are able
to launch cruise missiles in the event
of a conflict
guam has been threatened before in 2017
north korea said it would fire missiles
at guam and in a video released on
social media last year china's air force
hinted that a u.s base on guam could be
a target
walking around the naval and air bases
here which the wall street journal was
given access to it's not hard to see why
an adversary might take interest in the
major military facilities and assets
that would play a key role in a
confrontation what do you say to locals
here who are concerned that the more
service members and more assets arrive
on guam the more guam becomes a target
we actually had a lot more people here
during the height of the cold war i
wouldn't necessarily would uh say that
it would make us more of a target but um
certainly
we put enough assets here it also makes
it
easier for us to defend the area when we
have additional resources here guam is
already home to a key missile defense
system which we were invited to film
along with the iron dome
just a few hundred yards behind iron
dome is the thaad launcher the terminal
high altitude area defense system and a
big reason why iron dome is here in guam
in the first place is to see if these
two systems can work together
the testing aims to determine whether
data from both systems can be
transmitted back to hawaii in a way that
allows them to function alongside each
other
thaad is designed to detect and
intercept ballistic missiles like some
of the nukes developed by north korea
and china but it's not designed to
intercept short-range threats like
cruise missiles which fly on flat direct
paths that are more difficult for
missile defense radars to pick up so
systems like the iron dome could
potentially fill that gap we always like
to operate layered
so we never want just one layer of
defense so multiple layers is something
that we're always looking to achieve so
far the military says the iron dome has
shown encouraging results in terms of
integrating with that and it has worked
well in guam's hot and humid environment
plus the testing being done here could
help inform a new defense system being
developed for the army by dinetics since
the military doesn't plan to buy
additional iron domes
did we have anything at this lower level
before iron dome we have other air
defense systems
but we don't have a lot of them in our
arsenal so the more that we're able to
use and employ
the more flexibility we have with
defense and planning
the iron dome is scheduled to return to
the mainland in december and the data
from the testing will be analyzed as
part of a bigger plan to achieve a 360
degree defense of guam
[Music]